When you think of an extrovert odds are you're imagining a loud obnoxious party animal.
Instead of falling back on old often inaccurate stereotypes, we want to focus on the strengths of extroverts.
We encourage you to do the same. Here are six things extroverts are best at doing.
Number one, extroverts are enthusiastic.
According to research, extroverts are actually wired to be enthusiasts because they strongly associate their environment with rewards.
This is why they're often known as the life of the party in some circles.
Studies have shown that when people find themselves in a positive experience, they are likely to move faster, remember better and take on an optimistic demeanor.
This is very much instant gratification for an extrovert who is motivated by their impulse to be happy.
Number two, they're natural risk takers.
While risk is often negatively associated with reckless and unhealthy choices, in healthy doses, risk-taking is actually one of the best things you can experience.
Extroverts are always searching for the next exciting adventure, whether it'd be traveling the world, having an unconventional career or creating the latest invention.
Extroverts are one of a kind. Thanks to biology, dopamine is more active in their brains.
Dopamine is the neurotransmitter in our brains which motivates us to seek external rewards and take risks.
This makes extroverts natural explorers and the least boring people you'll ever meet.
Number three, they're able to make friends from all walks of life.
Their friendly and easygoing disposition makes them easy to talk to, which often attracts many people to them.
They enjoy variety and rarely fall in with cliques too.
Since extroverts are not intimidated by large social gatherings, they are also skillful at navigating their way around like a butterfly and network while also making it a fun enjoyable experience for everyone.
Number four, their curiosity brings them unique experiences.
Adventure is always out there and extroverts take the leap to embrace it.
Their curiosity helps them gain knowledge about the world, that can make them wise informative individuals with great stories to tell.
Number five, they're likely to succeed in their career.
Extroverts make great workers because they're highly conscientious individuals.
They are constantly figuring out how things work and are motivated by challenges.
This enthusiasm and creative problem-solving sets them apart from their peers, making them approachable leaders, but also great team players.
Since extroverts are people-oriented, they value interpersonal connections with their co-workers and are always willing to reach out to check in with someone to see how they're doing.
This mutual openness really helps a company grow closer as a unit.
Number six, they're open with their feelings.
Making a good impression is what helps land a job interview or score a first date.
But vulnerability is the essential ingredient for cultivating deep relationships.
Because extroverts are open about their feelings, as well as the feelings of others, they open the line of communication easily.
While introverts are widely considered interesting because of their mysterious nature, the more underrated extroverts' transparency makes them endearing and honest individuals.
What are some other good traits that extroverts have? Let us know in the comments below!
If you liked this video be sure to check out our website and other social media as well as our patreon account.
And don't forget to like and subscribe. As always, thanks for watching.